حرب زادت من ثقل الوضع الاقتصادي على
الاهالي في السودان
ازمه امتدت في كل ولايه السودان واشتدت في
الولايات الشماليه
طحو المواد الغذائيه بدا واضحا في سوق
القرير في مروي
ارتفاع في الاسعار وشبه عجز في القدره
الشرائيه للمواد الغذائيه ان وجدت خضار
وصل الى 300 حتى 400 في المئه عزاه البعض
الى استغلال التجار للازمه
في رمضان كانت بالفعل
التيار الكهربائي زاد الطين بالله ما اضرب
بمخزون الغذاء بعد الاحداث
طارت
يشتري ان شاء الله
ومع استمرار المعارك يتوقع تضرر مخزون
الغذائي في عبوم السودان لنحو كارثي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات